I wish you start a band
yes yeah good one two three
what should we name the band water
buffalo who are you drummer Peach Pit no
Sasha Malia and the Moroccan Lords this
is all ridiculous no slow down my steam
train I quit
you guys really suck are you thinking
are you in the back work no I'm coming
in on your signal what about that chord
I don't like minor fifths we're trying
to concentrate
bring out the rush is it the chorus I'm
the lead singer obviously what nanu-nanu
I write all the songs well I read all
the melody but that's the least
important part throw your photo by the
way he's gonna ask me hey we're in a
band
hey we are in a band
hey I'm I'm in a band really do you guys
need a lead singer hey who's this this
is Gabby I love the whole vibe you guys
have going here it's like so cute but I
was wondering if you guys have ever
tried to sound a bit more like a pixie
we zerlings Clearwater Revival bikini
killed Mac Rihanna you tried to be like
32% more pumps a great idea thank you
baby
we really need to focus on music right
now we have a show and if gab you sing
song track can I talk to you for a sec
Chris hey you're coming to the show
tonight right it's gonna be so much fun
I'll buy you a beer come on we need six
people or we're gonna pay for all these
tickets mom please buy these tickets
grandma
hey man geez all those tickets what the
hell is we talked about this she's
filling out the soundman okay well I
quit I quit looks like you have a couple
of holes to fill gonna do things a bit
differently miss okay but we gonna name
the band to litoris she's on a Sunday oh
yeah what for